comic fans have a pretty unhealthy habit
of comparing interpretations of their
favorite characters to one another be it
the age-old which is the best spider-man
argument which cinematic Batman has the
highest kill count or which version of
the Hulk was the most disappointing but
so far as an outsider to the community
I've noticed the TMNT fans either a
don't compare versions of the characters
at all for some reason or be just just
don't really talk about the turtles at
all they're so shy about it it's such a
nice quiet little phantom that just
enjoys seeing the four teenage reptiles
get any representation at all even if
it's the Michael Bay kind over the past
year I watched both of the most recent
completed TMNT shows and I felt like I
had a lot to say about them so imagine
this is a review for both at the same
time hopefully without causing a war and
disturbing the natural order
I can discuss something I see few people
discussing which Ninja Turtles cartoon
was the best however that question comes
with some caveats for a few reasons I
don't want to include the 80s cartoon
into this analysis mainly because it has
a hundred ninety-three episodes on my
Jesus I'm a bandwidth-limited spare time
as it is I can't really devote the time
to all that without this video coming
out in three years additionally that one
feels the most nostalgic for me since I
had quite a few VHS tapes full of
episodes from it growing up while these
other two shows I never really sat down
and like watch them until 2019 they're
both more fresh in my mind and lastly
the 80s animated turtles are really hard
to compare with these other ones because
it made such big strides to be its own
thing with the light-hearted tone the
colorful and well-defined characters and
the kid-friendly action scenes it was a
far cry from what the Ninja Turtles were
intended to be violent murderous
sewer monsters don't [ __ ] cut you to
pieces
there's some crazy weird Frank Miller
books daredevil was there too I guess
but people forget about that I'm also
not including rise of the TMNT because
it's not over yet and I haven't been
able to watch much of it so far I think
it's really cool and I'd be open to
doing a follow up to review it along
with the other two for those that don't
know because they're living in a sewer
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles are a
group of four mutated animals that gain
intelligence and humanoid bodies through
an accident involving that green
chemical stuff that you found in a
bottle under the sink and desperately
want to taste they're led by a humanoid
rat named splinter that trained the four
of them in the art of ninjutsu to defend
themselves and stay hidden from a world
that's prejudiced against green people
with shells the details about their
origin beyond that or shaky and heavily
subject to change depending on which
interpretation watch Helens some of the
comics they're the five reincarnated
souls of a ninja master and his sons
that were killed in feudal Japan but
we're not talking about that both the
2003 series and the 2012 series make
strides to blend the lightness of the
eighty show with the darkness of the
comic in varying ratios and I think it's
what makes them both so unique so let's
look at it like the comic book in the
80s cartoon or both of the parents of
the general idea of Ninja Turtles one
contributed the majority of the premise
plot lines and aesthetic while the other
contributed the more defined characters
from their tone and widespread
mainstream appeal both are awesome in
their own right and you have to commend
the cartoon for developing the
personalities of the turtles a little
more as well as giving them their own
color schemes because telling these guys
apart in black and white is a nightmare
if they aren't holding a weapon plus all
the turtles personalities during that
time were the angry one ironically as a
kid I couldn't tell Leonardo and
Donatello apart because I'm colorblind
in that they just look that looks the
same I find it interesting that the 2003
show is almost word-for-word adapting
scenes from the original comic our backs
are up against the wall in some trash
room alley
cornered by the toughest street gang on
the Eastside nobody messes with the
purple dragons especially wearing stupid
Turtle costumes who's wrong we're not
wearing costumes
while the 2012 show tries to emulate and
modernize more stories and characters
from the 80s cartoon
they both do their thing based on the
legacy of their parent of choice if the
2012 show does adapt any stories from
the comics it's very sparingly and with
a different twist with our focus
narrowed to just these two let's compare
and contrast what they both got right
and well what they don't the Ninja
Turtles wouldn't be the famous brand
they are without such iconic characters
everyone has their own favorite because
each one is so different from the rest
Raphael is the edgy angry hothead with a
temper Mikey is the fun-loving party guy
Donatello is the brains the operation
and Leonardo is the the leader the
serious one the responsible I'm gonna
lose a few subs over this but Leonardo
is usually the least interesting one
TMNT 2003 everyone's pretty much where
they should be including Leo the Turtles
banter is usually pretty jokey and fun
making them feel like old friends I'd
like to see you try on it Kim would you
wish for
Linda Junior they're the perfect blend
of serious and comical and I think they
took a lot of cues from the 90s movie to
get that ratio just right I especially
love their look in this show as they
remind me of like an Edie McGinnis
Deadpool comic visually however I think
the 2012 show took the characterization
a little further and added more depth to
each turtle not a lot mind you but more
than they had particularly leo the 2012
series goes out of its way to explain
his desire to be a leader he's more of a
sci-fi and fantasy nerd who enjoys
watching this Star Trek knockoff cartoon
because he admires the main character so
much for being a captain and he also
likes LARPing more
live-action role-playing if being a
giant turtle monster didn't ensure his
virginity was secured that sure did only
losers play dress-up I appreciate them
giving him hobbies him liking comics and
cartoons and nerdy stuff helps him feel
less like a bland over serious chump he
and the other turtles finally have
something to talk about other than just
giving them orders
I've also noticed that the 2012 Turtles
tend to bicker more and not just in a
short sassy way where they just
exchanged a few one-liners I mean really
argue in that regard I feel like their
relationship as brothers is more
believable because they get on each
other's nerves but they also feel more
openly affectionate to each other to
when they're not fighting I feel their
family bond is more fleshed out and real
I also really dig the voice actors they
got for both shows each respective cast
feels perfect for the version they're in
and seeing as how the 2012 show is more
influenced by the 80s cartoon it's
fitting that they got back the original
voice actor for Rafael SIF play
Donatello why do you sound so weird me
sound weird heard yourself lately hey I
do however kind of wish they hadn't
recast Leonardo halfway through the show
after his original voice American Pie
man got canceled for a controversial
tweet so like why does he sound
different you sustained damage to his
throat after that he was some guy who
sounded close enough for three episodes
and then they finally committed to
recasting in his Seth Green I know we
shouldn't trust karai but still I got
the sense she really is fed up with
shredder okay we need to come up with a
plan part one is Mikey stays here you've
been messing up too much lately we can't
take the chance she gave me a clue where
she is though she pointed east and said
comet his delivery for the lines is so
different the voice is so far from what
it was he almost feels like a different
character after that between the two
versions of them splinter is still a
loving father in each who wishes the
best for his sons both splinters
occasionally make wisecracks that catch
the turtles off-guard and both can be a
badass when necessary they differ in
that 2012 splinter isn't really like
elderly he's most likely in his mid-40s
at the latest they give him the
background of being ninja master Hamato
Yoshi instead of being his pet which is
another inspiration from the 80s cartoon
with that background his connection with
the shredder is more personal because
they were essentially brothers I prefer
this younger more badass
splinter especially since he's so tough
even all four Turtles at once can't
quite beat him in a serious fight Casey
Jones from the 2003 series has to take
the prize though it feels as if they
just directly transplanted him from the
90s movie and looks and personality the
2012 take is interesting though but I
don't think the decision to make him an
April so young ultimately added anything
I just really don't like his costume I
will give Josh Peck props for some solid
voice acting though then there's April
aside from being the human confidante
and like a big sister to the Turtles
these takes are pretty drastically
different the 2003 version is almost one
to one from the comic and her origins
also where she lives her personality a
lot of her storylines 2003 April is
definitely the most accurate take from
the comics of thus far well the 2012
April O'Neil is just something else but
one I think making her some kind of
special mutant shows in one with super
powers was kind of terrible at the very
least it wasn't executed in a way that
was very satisfying there's some kind of
half-assed backstory about her mother
being experimented on before she was
born by a race of interdimensional
beings called a nod to the 80s character
as a result she's now unable to be
mutated she's able to sense other
mutants at a distance it can use
telekinesis and splinter trains her to
be a ninja on par with the turtles in
like less than a year I can get behind
the idea of making her special and
allowing her to be a member of the team
as a fighter because you know that's not
new but by the end of this series she
just feels overpowered and the
explanation and introduction of all this
back stories really clumsily thrown into
quick dialogue and maybe three scenes
throughout the show that every character
just accepts it moves on the kraang
water for some kind of plot to take over
the world but after it fails once they
never really go after her again and just
write it off as a goof whoops I think it
would have been better if they committed
more fully to making April a chosen one
instead of
it so early and I especially think they
could have done with just giving her one
combat thing instead of two because
being a ninja and telekinetic that's
overkill man she's basically kenchi with
eyes I have to mention the relationship
of both April's April and Casey in the
2003 show is a really fun background
element that they develop in a realistic
way over the series but it's never
distracting or overwhelming at first she
can't stand the guy and he thinks she's
pretty stuck-up but as they save each
other's lives and get more involved in
crazy [ __ ] they start to see each
other's good sides and at the end of the
series they get married in an episode
that feels really earned for both of
them 2012 April and Casey definitely
flirt but never really date per se
because the show is too interested in
this god-awful love triangle with
Donatello yes Donatello desperately
wants to show April his bo staff
throughout the show and his jealous of
Casey but she never ends up with either
of them and they attempt to resolve the
triangle multiple times
April lets him down gently and he's like
okay yeah I can take a hint then the
next episode after that he's crushing
again it's especially frustrating when
he goes hey sorry I'm being weird and
overbearing all back off now and then
she kisses him on the cheek and
encourages him again
she's kissing him constantly and just
making it worse at the end of the day
this just means I really can't tell what
April wants as a character or where the
writers were intending to go with this
because eventually they just drop it
entirely around the middle of the fourth
season without any conclusion I guess
maybe they didn't have a plan for it and
being wishy-washy about the direction
just led them to giving up on it because
it wasn't getting any
oh geez too much talking about awkwardly
aborted relationship subplots I feel
like we're talking about Star Wars let's
talk about the villains I'm sorry to
have to cut this video and half dear
viewers but I need to get something
uploaded and I need to let you all know
that here at old Godzilla Mendoza
industries we've fallen on some hard
times January in February the lowest
months for views and revenue for any
youtuber and it's become increasingly
clear that using YouTube ads as my main
source of online income is preposterous
so now I'm doing the Burnie meme and
asking for your help I know I don't
advertise my patreon often but I figured
that if just 3% of my subscribers on
YouTube gave me one dollar a month just
one dollar I'd be pretty much set
forever so I'm asking you please be in
that 3% to help me keep the lights on so
I can keep making these videos part two
of this on the way soon
[Music]
[Music]